I'm gonna go to this clip and get your
take on it okay me and me and Jesus I
killed I'm killed but all the gods gods
recognize gods all right so what are
your thoughts on when you hear something
like this yeah I mean obviously you see
you see that you hear the people
laughing at what he says and you see a
lot of it what he does is like an act
and people find it very entertaining and
this is how he got popular this is how
he you know is the biggest highest-paid
fighter in that and stuff like that so
and actually I was reading a book and
it's interesting and many of us as
Muslims we know this that a lot of these
fighters whatever whatever they're in a
lot of these sports figures to be honest
for the last 40 years all they've been
doing is imitating Muhammad Ali trying
to be like Muhammad Ali because Muhammad
Ali was someone who came along at a time
when boxing was a little struggling a
little bit and he but he was able to
with his personality and by saying
things that were got people's attention
and seemed crazy and by making big
boasts and then backing it up he got
like people really loved that so a lot
of people so he's trying to do that act
of kind of imitating but you see that he
kind of I especially for us as Muslims
than anyone who understands the reality
of the seriousness of these things he
goes far overboard here you know and he
says things that he thinks are funny but
that really showed that he doesn't
understand what he's talking about so
you see first he's saying that him and
him and Jesus are cool Man Alive that
can be me
but Jesus ain't alive is he so I don't
you know maybe you could come back from
the dead nah I don't know
I'd still bloopers you know it's like
he's he's you know and this is this is
something that but at the same same time
he sees Jesus as a human being that he
can kind of be cool with and interact
but at same time then he goes say that
Jesus is like a god and he's also a god
so you see the danger of not recognizing
this separation between humans and God
and understand that and and that
understand we are not gods and we are
not we shouldn't put ourselves in that
level and that was something Muhammad
Ali for the most part he he was careful
about for the most part he would say
that you know I'm beautiful I'm pretty
I'm great I'm the greatest of the people
but he would normally not compare
himself to God but even he realized that
he kind of maybe went overboard at times
in the way he would boast and talk about
himself and that that when you do that
sometimes God humbles you too because
and not because God doesn't like you and
it's not even but actually if God umbels
you in this life when you're saying
something like that
it's actually a sign that God wants
something good for you that's that you
can could have let you keep going and
going and not humble you but now is the
time to reflect that's exactly what we
want we want to take this situation and
derive some good for it from it and just
like at a time you know this is amazing
we had the famous George st. Pierre
who's a UFC fighter we did a show
specifically also for him I can't I
can't sleep at night now I'm going crazy
at the shoes man and I need to relax I
need to get out for a while you know I
don't know what I'm gonna do and yeah
I'm I'm I feel like I'm gonna laugh
everything out now but I have to keep
some of my stuff some of part of my life
personal okay now his boxing trainer is
also Muslim so we know so he actually
contacted us and he he said that he sent
that show to him
so it got to another UFC champ now we
got another UFC champ that we want to
get the message to so we're going to
leave all of your guys help to help this
to go out now we want to derive some
good from it so we talked about you know
one quality of you can't go wrong with
is controlling that ego and and being
humble you know ii mean this is
something that all the messengers of god
taught knowing your limits and you
mentioned muhammad
you know we know I want aspect it's show
business right and many people don't
understand that even as human beings you
know you'll say one word you'll destroy
a marriage you'll say the wrong
paragraph wrong side you end up in life
in jail in prison but now the words we
say against the Almighty I'm killed with
all the gods gods recognize gods and
then the God came and bless you Willie
ya know about that coffee think any man
God made you know I mean not only that a
what God as well had the one who's
created us giving us all these blessings
that you couldn't even throw a punch
a jab block a punch without these
blessings from God to insult God like
this are we thinking what do you think
yeah no this is and like we said that's
why it's good that God humbles us
sometimes and we all have that this in
our life even if we're not you know
champions and we're not in show business
we all have times will become who think
they're going well we become very sure
of ourselves we think oh I have this job
I have this car I have this money
because of me because I work hard and
sometimes God has to Humble us a little
bit and many of us have this experience
through sicknesses through illness
through some losing someone close to us
we suddenly realized like we have
nothing like everything we have God just
gave it to us out of his you know mercy
and his compassion towards us and we
should just be grateful for it the main
thing is to be grateful for what we have
and always be humbled like as you said
to realize that everything we have is
from is from God is not from ourselves
how is the situation with the Irish
people are have they been I mean we have
one example like Liam Neeson you know
him yeah he was in Turkey at one time he
couldn't stand at a time but after some
time he was just like there was word of
him actually accepting Islam he's Irish
also right he is Irish he is Irish yeah
and you know and I think that he said
that he you know he began to appreciate
the the beauty of the
of the event in the culture and you find
out with many people at the Irish one
good thing we recently say as Irish is
that Irish are people of course even
though we're in Europe which is true of
some other people here we were at we
were not one of the people colonizing
people but we were colonized by the
English so Irish were people on the
bottom of the reign in Europe and people
have a long history of being oppressed
and of identifying with other oppressed
groups so you find so many people Irish
people identifying with Palestinians
identifying with their struggle
identifying with struggles all over the
world identifying with different
cultures so you have many Irish people
who are close to Muslims and who know
Muslims but now you know but but not
they're not necessarily a religious
connection but they're connecting on
cultural and other ways so we want to
know that again it's important to this
Islam is a message for everyone and we
want to you know share the message in
the best way possible we have to be the
best example I'm sure I like that we're
gonna take a break but that's right
Muslims right now it's sad to say I'd
probably the most oppressed people on
the earth Irish have gone through we got
another connection we got more
connections to talk about don't go
anywhere Connor
we'll be right now.we there's not a god
all right you don't believe in God if I
told you to this glass sprang into
existence this glass made itself no man
made this glass did you believe it would
you believe I just told you this thing
made itself
well I tell you you and Leah right no I
some somebody's doubting it yeah so I'm
giving you up so that she wouldn't
believe if I turn it was television
station popped into existence it's just
no man made it
you said Muhammad Ali's crazy all right
well this glass can't make itself if I
told you those clothes you have on wove
themselves
nobody created them those clothes made
themselves you and believe it but if
your clothes didn't make itself if that
glass couldn't make yourself if this
building didn't make itself then how did
the moon get out there how do the stars
and Jupiter Neptune and Mars from the
Sun how did nature how I'll always come
here didn't know why something planning
to make it so what I'm saying is I
believe that we're gonna be judged
should a man like Hitler kill all the
Jews and get away with it somebody
should punish it maybe get it don't get
it now you get it when you die it helped
eternity so what I'm gonna do when I get
out of boxing is to get myself ready to
meet God because my plane might blow up
don't planes blow up in this country
sometimes crash don't people die every
day subscribe right now
[Music]
back here on the Dean show with my Irish
brother here we did a show it was back
it was SD actually standard there and
our HD and it was called Irish and
loving Islam you actually come from a
background of being a Christian and you
actually tell us in summary what what
had you so interested I you I know you
read a Autobiography of Malcolm X and
yeah and and many other things but in
summary what was it about Islam that
captivated you captive so as you said I
grew up you know grew up in a Catholic
family as most Irish people are Catholic
and actually it's very intertwined with
the culture and but you know as most
people by the time I was in high school
in college I wasn't really into religion
you know I was into other things at that
time but I got fascinated with
african-american history and with
Malcolm X so I became really into the
into Malcolm X and studying from a
historical perspective but you know
Malcolm X one thing that he stressed and
Malcolm X spent most of his life even
though he was a powerful political
figure he actually spent most of his
time trying to teach people about Islam
and recruiting people to Islam first in
the Nation of Islam but then when he
realized the Nation of Islam was not the
total truth when he accepted Sunni Islam
he spent his time trying to teach people
about Sunni Islam and trying to attract
people to them and he especially said
for white people in America that they
should study Islam that because of his
powerful experience on Hajj where he
writes that amazing letter he felt that
this is something Islam if it's actually
taken in and actually appreciated and
practiced is actually something that can
destroy racism and something that can
bring people true Brotherhood and that
is actually what I did find myself when
I became Muslim when I was the first
spending time around Muslims in the
college setting and that's why I love
the college setting and so I came back
to be a chaplain you have Muslims from
all over the world you know we maybe had
10 different 10 15 different Muslims
that are gathering for iftar each one
coming from a different country in the
world but all bound together by by Islam
by by the their love of allah subhana wa
ta'ala by their love of the prophets
peace be upon him and just being so
humble and i remember sharing an iftar
and we're all sitting on the floor and
just you know after that period of
fasting you're finally getting some food
and you feel so calm and you feel the
brotherhood and sister
and that was actually what made me feel
just in my heart that this is the truth
that this is what Allah wants for us
similar to the experience that Malcolm
had when he was on it's pretty clear
when you look in Islam the purpose of
life why we're being created it's not
just blind faith there's evidence proof
it's overwhelming when you look at it
there's no other way that you're going
to look left or right but you got to
look straight say this is indeed you
know like you know there's no other
explanation for it then and then being a
way of life from the Creator it's
amazing and that's why I said like I
said like it you know now I work at a
Catholic University I have probably even
more understanding for for Catholicism
than I did in the past but and you see
why naturally human beings and you find
many of the principles being taught that
are the same principle then you see why
humans are attracted to it but the basic
thing about Islam that I think will
always win anyone who seriously looks at
is just the LA ilaha illa Allah there is
no god but God there's nothing worthy of
worship except God so everything else in
this world is creation it's something
different than God God's creation don't
worship the creation worship the creator
that makes sense to anyone who thinks
about it and I think that's where people
end up they turn away from religion they
go away from what their parents were
upon because now making God into a man
and now you can envision throwing a jab
at him or a cross I'll knock him out
that can be me but Jesus ain't alive is
he so I don't know maybe he could come
back from the dead nah I don't know
I'd still go bust you can't do that with
God because God's not a man nor did he
die on the cross I mean and that that
concept just makes sense what you're
saying worship the Creator not the
creation and from there your heart just
Manzini recognizes the Fatah
let me go to the next clip because
there's a lot of people that are upset
one Christian pastor in particular let's
see what he had to say I'm telling you
what I'm gonna pray that God strikes
this guy dead do you know why he's name
is Conor McGregor yes and he's a UFC I
mean these somebody hey these guys are
talking about strike him dead I mean and
I think that guy's probably trying to
get some attention but but but we know
that anger comes on and we know in the
Muslim community sometimes our anger
comes out when people say things that we
know are out of line out of pocket but
as we start it off by saying the point
really is not for us as human beings to
become angry with people especially if
they haven't even been given the message
but to go and just talk to them and try
to give them the message and like you
said make something positive come out of
it like a loss Allah you see the way
that Allah if Allah wanted to strike him
dead when he said that Allah what could
have struck him dead when he finished
boom it would be over Allah doesn't want
to do that Allah is giving him more time
because Allah wants to teach him
something give him a chance to change
and so we hope he takes that opportunity
definitely and maybe people want to make
Muslims not like you know where the
where the vigilantes and violent but we
got a message of love and hope and we
want him now God Almighty a lot of times
my next question we put in all of this
work in this effort we pound our chest
and we say IIIi did as my training I you
know without that but what about the
other element because again we couldn't
if we didn't have this air to breathe
the eyes to see with if we didn't have
the nerves inside of our bodies you know
just a disc goes out l4 ll back the back
eight nine discs
you're out you're done you can't do
anything subhanAllah and like I said
before that's the one thing that you
realize especially if you're sick or
something and you need help you can't
even get up and go to the bathroom for
yourself you can't do anything for
yourself you really realize how weak you
are and like I said and Allah mentions
this in the Quran that the human being
when they get wealth when they get
status they tend to become arrogant
and sometimes Allah has to Humble us to
remind us of what's really going on and
inshallah the best of us are people who
have that humility even if we're given
blessings and then alive we're grateful
when we're giving blessings instead of
becoming arrogant if we're just grateful
for it and try to use it for good then
Allah will keep giving us more and more
blessing so how could he now he's tuning
in the message gets to him how can he
take this situation he hears this now
because every heart he's you know you
mentioned african-americans he loves the
you know the bling-bling the hip-hop you
know he can go back and connect with the
roots of Kunta Kinte and Malcolm X
Muhammad Ali they all found purpose in
submission to the will of God Islam they
found purpose then they found
contentment but will you ever doesn't
matter how many Rolls Royces you have
how many Lambos how many selfies and
muscles you grow is that where the
purpose is and contentment and happiness
yeah no it isn't and I think you can
talk to people who have those things and
a lot of times they put on the front
just like put on the front for the
purpose of show business a lot of times
people put on the front and if they fake
picture that this is bringing them
happiness that's bringing contentment
but deep in their heart they know when
they're alone when they're reflecting
when they've gotten a little humbled
that this is not bringing them happiness
and but we want to know that happiness
is out there and don't don't keep
chasing it through material things don't
even keep chasing it through Fame and
whatever you got Fame because you have
certain skills you have certain
blessings people like your personality
that's okay but now use that to show
people that you you can still learn and
grow this is what we love about Malcolm
X Muhammad Ali any people that we look
up to they may have gained their fame
through different reasons but what I
think makes them people that we still
talk about now and people that people
still love and look up to rather than at
people that were forgotten is that they
were humble enough to learn lessons to
improve to grow and to change so we
always want to be able to change and I
think that's that's what we would love
to see from Conor McGregor we're very
well known make a change come to some
day I mean it will be beautiful you know
there's other other famous Irish Muslims
like Everlast the rapper from House of
Pain and stuff I really feel like he
could be star if he could be part of
sort of movement to show that being
Irish and being
Muslim makes sense together and that's
about worshipping the Creator not the
creation is something I guarantee a feat
sincere and he looks into it he would
indeed see that it provides all the
evidence rational logical and there's no
other way but to see that this is the
truth look another misconception that is
clear right now just by us sitting
together
look bosnian American Irish we talked
about African American Muhammad Ali and
it's for the whole of mankind because
it's a universal message we'll be right
back with more Hannity show don't go
anywhere subscribe right now
[Music]
here on the Dean show you know certain
stereotypes are attached to certain
people and I know I mean I'm just
sitting with a perfect example of an
Irish Muslim that he's got to go beyond
in the beer and you know the foul
language there's got there's more to
life and people in this position now the
young kids will look at someone like
that a celebrity status and start to
think imagine everybody starts thinking
that they're gods gods recognize gods
you know what I mean now we've gotten
more towards you know up paganism and
setting the worst of examples because
now we're just lost a soul is just
bankrupt you might have all the money
but your soul and heart is dead but
there's more there's got to be that the
Irish people will connect with this
message because it's in all of us
I definitely and I think you know I
think we all find a lot of people
especially for Irish people who are in
America now most of them have been here
for a while their families have been
here for many generations they kind of
hummed a lot there's a strong sense
where people still hold on to being
Irish because that means something to
them but unfortunately too many of them
it means something silly as we'll see
and March 17th comes around it means to
them getting drunk you know it's
partying all day like this is somehow
showing pride in being Irish this has
nothing to do with what being Irish is
really all about
what does Irish being all about so I
mean being Irish like I said is all
about really for the people come there
is really about siding with the
oppressed it's really about faith family
you know it's really about identifying
with the people who who are downtrodden
and really standing up for what's right
as well as having you know an ancient
culture and ancient traditions that that
we try to you know uphold and try to
follow but those traditions are based on
values that we find in Islam they're not
based on values of partying and material
that consumers culture like we were
talking about and so that's a really sad
and this is why one thing about Islam is
that the Prophet peace be upon him he
taught us to know your lineage to study
your history to know where your people
came from why not because to be overly
proud of it or nationalistic or in terms
of separating from other people but we
like we said the Muslims are all United
together and we
unite humanity together under Islam but
when you know where you came from when
you know your values it helps you to
know other people better it helps you to
know what's important as you know a god
says in the Quran that we made you in
two different nations and tribes so that
you might know one another so the fact
that we're in different nations the
tribes is not an accident it's not a
mistake
God did it on purpose and there's value
in knowing that but once you know what
that really is about what's a really
true nature of your heritage is about it
helps you to realize what's important in
life
and what's important in life is your
connection with the Creator and trying
to uphold values and help humanity let's
go and because it's about shifting
loyalty many people started to you know
large numbers fads coming in they feel
like okay now this is our man who
represents us and you're only as strong
is who you put all your effort in and
you see the at the end what goes up
comes down you're a human being you're
weak and hopefully this can be a
learning lesson for Conor McGregor to
turn that loyalty to the creator of the
heavens and earth Allah now tell us
what's in the last few minutes that we
have let's talk about some very
important concepts you talked about this
when we were an SD and we have great
feedback talking about the deep love
that we have for Jesus peace be upon him
you know but Jesus also never called
people to worship Him and people
understanding also the concept of
original goodness not original sin can
you get up into these core simple
beliefs that just resonate and I can I
guarantee if a person says here they'll
say I agree with that
and if you agree with that then you
should accept that mashallah I'm glad
I'm glad you mention that because I
think that is really important for
people who do have an attachment to the
faith you know Jesus is a very important
figure and and for all Catholics and all
Christians but you know in the Irish I
think they feel a special identification
with Jesus and with Mary especially and
these are figures that are in the Quran
the figures that are very important in
our faith but it's important not to take
them in the wrong way their beautiful
role models and beautiful examples of
human beings who were submitted to God
in the most perfect way not of people
who and we don't when we elevate them to
being God that's that's making a mistake
and that's really going astray and
you'll find a lot of people that's where
a lot of people do get confused because
they don't know what them
I mean I think they think they want they
want to have that identification to know
that God cares for them but the way to
do it is not by turning God into a human
being the way to do it is by realizing
that God cares for you as a human being
that God is there to answer your prayers
directly that you don't need to go
through any intermediary that you don't
need to go through a priest or a prophet
or anybody that the prophets give bring
messages but you you got you who speak
to God directly you pray to God directly
you're gonna stand before God alone on
the day of judgement and so you want to
have that relationship with God so
Christians who are listening to this
people who are interested should really
read about what the Quran says in the
chapter of Mary about Mary about Jesus
the example we have of Jesus's life
again was similar to what we say we
pride the Irish being about it Bob about
standing for the oppressed being
submitted to God bringing bringing
social change and really identifying
with the downtrodden in society and
that's what as we have people of faith
have to do what advice it's very hard
it's very tempting when the whole world
opens up to you now a person like her
Girma Connor who is that that you know
point where he's almost got everything
but definitely right now you can like
Ronda Rousey know if you heard of her
most popular woman in the world you know
thought she was unstoppable
and then she suffered a defeat and then
shortly after she's on an interview
talking about thinking contemplating
suicide right but you got everything you
got the Stata you could still make it
you found it so how what should someone
you know now it's like that humbling
point and you know maybe your your more
receptive to the message so what advice
do you have for someone like Conor
McGregor who's out there maybe you know
he's tuning in yeah I I hope he is I
hope this message reaches him this turn
really you know like we said this is an
opportunity to understand what's really
important I'm sure on some level you
know what's really important you know
who are the people and the things that
were important in your life before you
became famous the people who didn't just
jump on the bandwagon the people who
stick by you even if you lose those
those things that are important and God
is of those things God is always there
waiting for you regardless of what we
say about him
you know we as we as Muslims say that
God like the the greatest sin we can
commit is shirk and he is comparing God
to a human being
comparing God to his creation worshiping
something else along with God but even
with even when we do that we God is
waiting for us to turn back to admit our
mistake and God will definitely accept
as we say that if we take one step
towards God God will take two steps
towards us if we go to God walking God
will come to us running and that's a
very powerful statement because we know
God is not a human being God is not a
person but it's a very powerful
statement that the only barrier between
us and God is ourselves in our decisions
so really realize what's important
realize where you're gonna find
tranquility and happiness is with the
Creator and with making a life that's
really more meaningful than maybe what
you said what you thought before and I
think if you do that you have a
potential not just for yourself most
importantly but you have a potential to
influence a lot of people who are paying
attention who want to see what you're
gonna do next that's it because these
are planting grounds right now that we
plant them because all this all those
rolls-royce's I got to stay behind right
and we're gonna die now it's time to do
good deeds so they can flourish and we
can have the everlasting reward in the
next life god only thank you so much
thank you all good there's no peace be
with you someone like buddy comes down
there you have it mr. Conor McGregor I
hope that you really contemplate and
think about the message the wonderful
advice now just as managing I'm with
this story imagine if someone had given
you a shovel a light a road map water
and everything you needed to go ahead
and dig up a treasure you can find any
of these tools anywhere else in the
world but the person who gave it to you
that was the only one who had these
essential items that you couldn't see in
the dark without the light you couldn't
dig up that treasure without the shovel
you couldn't survive out there without
that water in that food and then you
ended up finding the treasure because
you had the treasure map the blueprint
on how to find it and then you finally
dug it up and you forgot to give thanks
to the one who gave you the shovel the
one who gave you the light the one who
gave you the food in the water and the
drain
and the roadmap how would that be you
think your trainer who helped train you
you think your wife who helped you
during those down trying times but now
the one who gave you the abilities and
the one who actually put that treasure
there who doesn't need any of it but
just put it there to test you that when
you achieve the success will you
recognise the one who gave you the
ability to be successful and now what
will you do with all of that
will you Bhosle praise yourself and make
yourself into a deity into a god and
then be humbled and now what will you do
with that warning that sign because it's
come to you or will you go ahead and
take the advice heed the call the
message and contemplate and think think
because deaf can approach at any time
and money and fame and prestige and all
of these things that we think that feed
our egos at the end all of this stuff we
leave behind in the grave really
contemplate the day that when you had
nothing and now you have something what
are you going to do to give back to
humanity to give back to society take
what you need but now to go ahead and
recognize the one who gave you these
abilities that you couldn't even throw a
punch a jab block one stand up tall
if it wasn't for the one who gave you
the ability who gave you everything that
you have to achieve this great success I
hope that Conor McGregor you will go
ahead and think and reflect and ponder
and at the end of the day it takes but
the sincerity and earnestness inside the
drive to just ask as the one thank the
one who made you who created you who
gave you all these faculties and
blessings to guide you and to start to
live a thankful grateful life and now
you in the position that you're in you
can make a huge impact of goodness and
plant seeds of goodness now so when you
leave this
life you can leave a legacy of good
because many have come and gone and
they've been forgotten but how will you
be remembered is how you live this life
and if you live the good life a good
life according to the way that the
crater wants you to live you will have
lived a successful life and then you'll
have not only success peace and
tranquillity and contentment and this
life that money cannot buy
but then definitely you will have
paradise in the next and this is the
message of all the messages including
Jesus peace be upon him Muhammad Moses
Abraham because they all call to the
same call to worship the Creator not the
creation and that's that simple message